[Music]
my double who's also one of my closest
friends but she did push me to get there
my stunt double and you can see that
it's me fighting which I'm proud of
Jennifer Garner takes no prisoners in
her new action thriller peppermint
judges dirty cops
[Music]
would you like to meet my team
Ultimatrix are you a little bit nervous
a little cuz few the whole nother level
she is my girl on the other side what is
it like working together because you
guys have formed the bonds we work
together since the second episode of
alias really until hell tied are you
know I just become her to look and what
am I gonna wear yeah she's then I'm
pretty much we get from there Shana show
me I think an elbow I think like a like
an uppercut okay
no no no bow I know what is this
uppercut so an uppercut you'd come in
here
mmm to the body uh-huh and then elbow
would come to the face she's like she
could kill you do you know that go ahead
do it full speed but I'm gonna back up
before - no no no okay go ahead I'm
gonna trust for more on Jen's intense
training for peppermint and some
seriously impressive fight moves with
her stunt double Shana watch et on
Monday August 20th
you